histoire vraie la prostitution de luxe
madame claude
je vous êtes dans ce domaine une légende
vivante on a écrit beaucoup d'articles
sur vous des livres des films ont été
tournés sur votre histoire et on
voudrait connaître ce soir vraiment
votre histoire vraie alors pour être
très clair
madame claude sa recouvrait quoi
exactement c'était un standard
téléphonique un bureau une maison de
rendez vous de lui que c'était quoi
non c'était uniquement à un réseau
téléphonique c'est à dire vous avez un
téléphone un téléphone jeux servaient
d'intermédiaires un fichier voilà c'est
tout c'est tout simplement je ne voyais
pas les garçons des filles puisqu'elles
étaient là mais je servais seulement à
des revenus commencent à elle était là
elle adore téléphone ou chez vous il y
avait 2 2
de différentes choses certes un nouvel
appartement
oui elle recevait chez elle qui d'autre
n'avait pas elle volant ce qu'on
appelait les volants que se rendait aux
adresses choisir un press-book pas du
tout c'était là où on était là l'astuce
est la difficulté à la fois c'est à dire
qu'il devait faire confiance je leur
posais certaines questions préférées
vous les blondes et brunes les grandes
et petites et à partir de ce moment là
je leur envoyais ce que je pensais être
ce qu'il désirait au début quand il
était nouveau et hésite un petit peu et
quelquefois me trompais et votre fichier
dans votre fichier il y avait combien de
finir au beaucoup moins qu'on a dit vous
savez une trentaine à la fois c'était un
peu près tous la pensée on a extrapolé
des centaines et des centaines sur 20
ans c'est vrai alors vous avez dit en
tout cas je crois que ça c'est vrai vous
avez dit et répété qu'il n'était pas à
la portée de toutes les filles
finalement d'entrer chez madame claude
sur quels critères de sélection vous
preniez vos filles qu'elles étaient les
qualités essentielles vous pouvez leur
demander et bien une certaine qualité
physique au départ il fallait qu'elle
soit grande qu'elle nous aide de jolis
gestes physiquement
qu'elles soient assez jolie s'était pas
seulement des critères de beauté il
fallait qu'ils aient une certaine
instruction d'une éducation une une
façon de voir les choses qui étaient un
peu la mienne ne plus les mêmes sinon ça
n'était pas possible on ne peut pas
travailler et tout cela avec des gens
qu'on sent mal ne sont pas bien avec
vous avec kim n'est pas que cette
instruction vous leur donniez
éventuellement si elle ne l'avait pas
exactement où des oui c'est bien vous
avez formé vos certaines l'avait donc il
n'y avait pas de problème d'autres il a
fallu un petit peu lutté je suis un
blessé c'était elle n'avait pas les
bases quand elle n'avait pas les bases
il fallait il fallait faire un site
moins physiquement c'est exactement la
même chose au début quand j'ai commencé
je me suis dit bon je ne vais prendre
que le très jolie fille puisque je
voudrais rester dans une certaine gamme
de deux garçons et de prix et puis je me
suis rendu compte que non il n'y avait
pas tellement de très jolies filles aux
n'est pas certaine et est grande et le
vin vilaine et ou de mauvaises dans
alors j'ai trouvé
les dentistes les chirurgiens qu'il
fallait et je les ai fabriqués
c'était donc une sorte d'investissement
donc jeu disons que j'ai aidé un peu la
nature on a dit là aussi mais je crois
que c'est vrai que vous faisiez tester
les compétences sexuelle des filles ça
fait légende ou réalité jamais côté
amusant de la chose disons que au départ
s'il n'était pas tout à fait habitué je
leur présentais plutôt des garçons que
vous connaissez bien dont j'étais sur
les hommes le jean petit mot d'ordre
c'est facile mais comme j'étais déjà il
me dit serait moi d'aller chanter cela
tout simplement
c'est toujours dans ces questions très
pragmatique qui vous voulez bien quelles
étaient les motivations de syfy qui
venait vous trouvez de leur plein gré la
première était l'argent c'est évident
d'autres
surtout parmi celles qui étaient mariés
quelquefois la la curiosité un certain
peut-être des enchantements chercher
quelque chose qu'elle n'avait peut-être
pas tout à fait tout à fait trouver des
femmes mariées un petit peu comme bell
de joie de jouer le double face à des
filles de familles aussi oui beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus qu'on ne croit
il est alors question encore peut-être
plus pragmatique quels étaient les
tarifs et quelle était la commission que
vous preniez sûr j'ai nagé pour les 30%
voilà donc 60% c'était 70 % pour elle
c'était les tarifs savez moi je suis
parti il ya presque quinze ans la grand
paris pour une soirée c'était 2000 2500
il ya 15 ans c'était ça semble cher
encore maintenant oui non on va passer
aux clients ou d'abord tout à l'heure
vous employez d'un autre mot parce que
oui car sans le mot client s'est mis en
mouvement disions jamais elle n'avait
pas le droit de prononcer ce on disait
les gars mais les garçons bon allez
jeunes filles et les garçons alors là
aussi côté client ce qu'il y avait une
sélection particulière oui au départ
nation rentrés dans la
alors on parle de permis à ces gars aux
deux princes 2 2 capitaines d'industrie
etc c'était vraiment ça oui tout à fait
tout à fait j'ai connu à peu près toutes
les têtes
oui mais comment étiez-vous et comment
vos filles étaient à l'abri d'un d'inde
exact c'est parce que il y en a aussi
on n'est jamais à l'abri de ce genre de
choses j'essayais quand je les faisais
vous ai parlé je suis de savoir si comme
c'était la première fois j'en voyais une
fille un peu plus aguerri et puis on
nous avait aussi consignes si quelque
chose ne déplaisait
je veux aussi de s'en mêler mais vous
avait-il de refuser certains garçons
mais donc par exemple et c'est l'exemple
de deux reçus et demander des choses
impossibles c'est arrivé ceux qui
avaient des voix déplaisante en général
de prison correspond à monsieur le vent
se
ce qui ne plaisait pas il y avait
quelques fois aussi
après une première expérience la jeune
fille en disant non c'est pas tout à
fait pour vous on ne revoyait pas quel
genre de client c'était quel âge de 17 à
577,1 vous êtes être un peu fade c'était
une forme de rêve que vous vendiez cia
et qu'elle rêve quel genre de femme est
ce qu'ils cherchaient la leur pendant un
peu plus jeunes la descente raide ifema
l'heure on est un peu plus jeunes et
surtout quelqu'un qui soit aussi bien
élevé que le fameux l'amphi laursen qui
ne leur pose pas de problème dit soit
aussi jolie que les
des deux cinémas ou mannequin et qui ne
reposent surtout pas de problème mais
est ce qu'il est arrivé que certains de
vos clients épouse finissait toujours
par toujours au parce que pour moi il ya
des grandes de voir avec un certain
sourire
ce qui est curieux c'est qu'on va quand
même pas dire que la prostitution parce
qu'il faut l'appeler par son ami omar
l'a conduit à la promotion à la
promotion sociale
c'est toujours chez moi elle repartait
toujours mieux qu'une telle qu'elle
était là c'est vous qui le dites c'est
ce qu'a dit non non c'est de savoir
quelles étaient les relations que vous
entretenez avec vos films vous vous
appelez bruit c'est une grande famille
une famille alors vous étiez plutôt aux
chefs d'entreprise imprésario ou
proxénète au profit net est un vilain
mot c'est vulgaire ont complètement je
viens de rassurer l'état mais pas
d'avoir le nom non on n'agit c'est nier
justement d'enlever tout ce qu'il y
avait d'un peu équivoque il de l'est
dans ce métier alors est-ce que vous
fîtes de leur côté accepté finalement
qu'on les appelle des prostituées se
tenait à ce que le monde était à bout
non pas du pas du tout et il est arrivé
un jour une histoire très amusante d'une
jeune personne que j'avais envoyé 1
garçons nouveaux clients et qui me
téléphonent moment après un pleurant
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous n'allez pas
être content mais je n'ai gillet il a
mis ça l'a fait et très bien au départ
et puis l' uvre à l'heureux il m'a
traitée de [ __ ]
je ne dis rien il ya eu un grand silence
elle me dit vous êtes toujours là oui
j'écoute série si une jeune personne
couche avec un monsieur simplement pour
de l'argent qui appelle ça comment ah
oui mais j'avais pas vu ça comme ça mais
n'a jamais ça j'étais très heureuse de
cette réaction parce que ça montre est
justement arrivé à l'enlever de leur
fait
si vous aussi été très belle vous me
disiez est ce que pour autant elle était
capricieuse et vos clients étaient très
riches
est ce que pour autant les était
capricieux c'est à dire 'est-ce qu'il
était difficile de gérer tout savoir les
caprices non vous avez de la poigne
ensemble mais je vais vous nous
racontiez parce que là on est là pour
tout dire deux exemples un exemple de ce
n'est pas moi d'un jeune homme que son
papa
vous aurez à mener où je parle heureux
arrivé souvent mais ça se passe et
comment
et bien le jour dans la question et
téléphoné il me disait ma chère j'ai mon
fils il ya vingt sept ans ou 17 ans qui
est un petit peu un petit peu nunuche un
petit peu peiné et j'aimerais que sa
première expérience et une bonne
expérience un bon souvenir
nous prenons rendez vous je les trouvais
une fille pas beaucoup plus âgé mais
quand même évolué et gentil et puis le
rendez vous était pris aux appartements
de la jeune personnes discutaient
dissidence et en gérer tout arriverait
très très très gentiment et ça se passe
est ce la meilleure amélioration
plusieurs de ces jeunes garçons sont
tombés follement amoureux de ses filles
on a eu quelques fois des problèmes
inversement je voudrais que vous nous
racontiez pour savoir jusqu'où ça peut
aller des raisons de refus je vous dis
celui qui demandaient des choses à fait
impossible c'était cela ce que je
n'aimais pas et ce que je ne tolérerai
pas par exemple c'était les gens qui
voulaient frapper par exemple se disait
toujours sourire mais fermement en
marchandises et trop délicate pour
supporter ce genre de manipulation alors
vous étiez une pro est considéré comme
tel
est-ce que
à votre insu ou vous même est ce que
vous avez travaillé pour disons ou
involontairement pour les rg ou les
services spéciaux ce que parce que vos
clients étaient quand même des gens
prestigieux et on se dit que sur 20 ans
vous n'avez pas pu exercer sans être
protégé finalement alors vous savez
c'était du donnant donnant non pas du
tout en aucune façon si j'étais sg 7
rennes moi je te dirai je n'avais pas
fait au petit personnel mais je ne
dirais pas cela il faut aller très haut
si on veut vraiment si on veut vraiment
être protégés bien longtemps c'est donc
ce qui était votre voile est au plus
haut oui voilà pourquoi pour quelle
raison je vois là vous êtes allé au plus
vous avez des étudiants les plus haute
protection
comment êtes vous tombé est ce qu'un
jour vous elle achète est ce que ce sont
les politiques et plus haut niveau qui
vous en alchimie nom final personne ne
m'a lâché ne pouvant pas m'atteindre
matin
le seul bien qu'on pouvait avoir une
histoire de la fiscalité c'est tout
comme en france est extrêmement batta au
lieu de faire quelque chose de déclarer
ce serait tout à fait tout à fait a
finalement très dense dans ce régime de
fiscalité on peut c'est impossible c'est
un métier comme un autre déclaré milla
c'était très vicieux parce que ils
voulaient toucher de l'argent le fils
que voulait toucher de l'argent sur
quelque chose qui n'était pas tolérer
qu'il n'existait pas on ne pouvait quand
même pas un proxénète de l'état c'est là
dessus que je me suis battu et quand
vous êtes tombé vous n'avez pas eu la
tentation de nom de parler de d'ouvrir
votre carnet d'adressés qui va se faire
c'est à ça que c'est une protection
protection sur le oui mais vous savez
ces garçons m'avez fait confiance
pourtant il y avait toujours ce carnet
non j'ai détruit tout cela dans une ce
que vous avez eu peur physique n'a pas
du tout je connais pas la peur vous avez
jamais été menacé non non non vous savez
pour faire ce métier sans avoir de être
menacés comme vous dites il faut s'en
tenir pour l'exercice strict de l'amitié
c'est à dire il ne faut pas permettre à
certaines personnes d'avoir prise sur
vous et pour cela il faut pas de
fréquenter il ne faut pas s'occuper de
drogue ne faut pas s'occuper de choses
qui ne se résume le milieu n'est jamais
mieux son humour le milieu ne faut pas
le fréquenter
c'est tout lorsque voilà à vous en
étonnez pas vulnérable on veut pas vous
attendent
c'est tout moi je ne sortais jamais
c'était un choix
je suis restée négative fiscalement
général si je puis dire et on vous avez
dû voir ça a été la seule façon comme le
capot mais pas exacte mais on n'a pas pu
la voir autrement lorsque vous voyez
toutes ces années passées qui vous
envoie lui
l'exil quelques quelques mois de prison
de grosses c'est une grosse expérience
vous avez de l'amertume vous avez un
sentiment de fierté non plus où l'idée
d'un peu trop de solitude bon maintenant
la solitude soit toujours été mon lot
fameux s'en va très bien pour moi ça
n'existe pas non je n'ai pas du tout
d'amertume si je devais refaire ma vie
je recommande
vous êtes justement vous avez été éduqué
chez les soeurs vous êtes né dans une
famille disons plutôt bourgeoise
qu'est-ce que vous entraîner à faire ce
métier vous savez après et après la
guerre nous avions tout perdu et j'avais
des charges de famille il fallait faire
quelque chose
je ne savais pas fait grand chose ou l
étude des tentes inachevé le rivella
dans une amie qui faisait une qu'elle
est petite agence contre là je me suis
dit au fond pourquoi pas c'est peut-être
très de mourir est vraiment pendant dix
ans sur tout ça m'a beaucoup amusé créé
changé mais les jeunes filles s'étaient
c'était très agréable
vous pouvez avoir le sentiment que ceux
qui nous écoutent actuellement qui nous
regardent peuvent se trouver peut-être
que vos propos sont signés ou qu'est ce
que vous leur dites n'en ont pas du tout
pas du tout je ne pense que je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas fait de tort c'est assez
jeune femme
bien au contraire elles sont sorties du
temps qu'elles sont passées chez moi
beaucoup mieux physiquement moralement
elles ont connu des gens qui n'y
auraient jamais approché autrement
souvent elles les ont quelquefois les
vrais épouse est souvent ces garçons
leurs avoirs qu'ils ont apporté beaucoup
non non je veux au contraire on ne pense
pas du tout qu'est ce que c'est l'amour
pour vous est-ce que c'est autre chose
que du sexe business
ont sûrement quelques coups puisque
certaines de mes filles qui étaient
partis pour faire du dans le chèque se
sont mariés oui beaucoup
et vous l'avez trouvé où on a fait des
soins par jour vous demander puisque
c'est pratiquement leur de terminer
maintenant à toutes les trois c'est à
dire madame claude à cynthia et esther
si vous concilie à des formes de
prostitution que vous ne mettez pas où
est ce que pour vous la violence ce soit
n'importe quelle forme alors je trouve
que bon ça existe ce ne sera pas les
risques du métier
oui / non pas vraiment je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas eu vraiment non non j'ai pas
mis enfin je suis tout à fait d'accord
il se trouve que la sexualité normale ça
suffit largement pour faire des affaires
ce n'est pas la peine d'aller plus loin
effectivement je trouve qu'il veut
beaucoup mieux que la jeune garçon se
rendre dans un bordel c'est là où il
apprendra tout moi mes enfants c'est
comme cela qu'ils ont commencé mon fils
je puis vous assurer qu'il est
parfaitement sain tout à fait stable
pour les questions à madame claude et
cynthia est ce que vous avez pensé à
votre avenir à vos vieux jours et très
pragmatiquement est-ce que vous avez mis
de l'argent de côté se dire est ce que
ce métier a été rentable pour vous
madame claude autant que pour vous fiez
en tout cas on vous en tendant à
l'impression qu'elles ont toutes réussi
oui c'est votre cas non non et d'argent
il a eu le fisc il passait par
actuellement à l'étude non je vis pour
ce que j'ai quelques amis qui sont
encore reconnaissant de moins en moins
parce qu'il fait à ces âges et moi j'ai
quand même chose quand c'est a alors
laissé autres il était un peu plus vieux
maintenant ça devient de plus en plus
difficile moi j'ai surtout travaillé
pour le gouvernement
j'ai eu quelques plaisir intellectuel
dirons nous
c'est afin d'apprécier la générosité de
quelques heures
[Musique]